[Música]
hola buenas noches gracias a todos por
venir y por escuchar lo que tenemos que
proponerles mi nombre renata becerril
como dijeron soy director ejecutiva del
festival internacional abierto mexicano
de diseño del que voy a hablar a manera
de conclusión al final de la plática
yo soy curadora de diseño crítica
también de diseño y arquitecta de
profesión decidí dejar la arquitectura
para entonces proponer desde una manera
tal vez desde lo abstracto cómo mejorar
nuestro entorno y cómo hacer de nuestras
vidas un lugar más feliz y como desde
nosotros como ciudadanos y como
creadores podemos hacer estas propuestas
sin necesidad de esperar desde afuera
que vengan estas propuestas sino desde
nosotros como cambiar nuestras
realidades
en esta plática defined reality
la la la
la título la apropiación afectiva del
espacio público es decir desde como
desde nosotros desde desde los
ciudadanos y desde la sociedad podemos
hacer cambios significativos para ocupar
de manera distinta y significativa el
entorno que nos rodea y dotarlo de
contexto dotarlo de nuevos valores y
hacer de ese espacio físico en donde
conectamos todos nosotros un mundo más
habitable más feliz para la comunidad
en donde nos conectamos voy a dividir
esta plática en cuatro secciones la
primera voy a hablar desde la parte de
la utopía desde unas utopías un poco
fatalistas pero no nos asustemos lo voy
a hablar desde unas utopías más
realistas y después voy a hablar de dos
soluciones unas soluciones históricas
que han permitido visualizar en un
futuro más deseable y después unas
soluciones más contemporáneas que en
donde podemos encontrar algunos ejemplos
de lo que proponen algunos creadores
algunos
de gobierno de cómo podemos apropiarnos
efectivamente del espacio que nos
circunda
quisiera empezar con una con una frase
que desde aquí parte un poco esta
visualización y es una una frase de un
pensador y filósofo francés michel
foucault y lo sitúa el porqué mucho de
lo que voy a estar hablando se relaciona
con este pensamiento francés esta
ideología francesa y me hice el foco en
uno de sus libros que se llama of other
spaces o utopías y heterotopías menciona
que en la época presente tal vez era
sobre todo la época del espacio este
espacio en donde se conecta no sólo de
manera física pero también de manera
virtual nuestra sociedad
cuáles son estas utopías fatalistas
bueno primero
quisiera hablar de un personaje un
arquitecto de la universidad de berkeley
que tiene varios libros entre ellos un
libro que se llama patria en lenguas en
donde menciona christopher se llama
christopher alexander donde menciona que
nuestra realidad física es mucho más
deseable cuando está construida desde la
sociedad no desde lo que esperamos que
los arquitectos son los urbanistas
construya sino desde la manera en que
nosotros utilizamos el espacio por
ejemplo en estas imágenes que son muy
clásicas de la vida newyorkina en donde
vemos estos edificios con las
escalinatas siempre afuera de los de
estos edificios altos o bajos las
personas cómo viven su contexto de
manera muy puntual y muy local y esto
permea a la ciudad y hacen la ciudad un
poco un poco más habitable entonces esto
es lo que lo que presenta christopher
alexander es decir como desde la
sociedad podemos apropiarnos y dar
significados nuevos valores al espacio
sin embargo ha habido pensadores que
vislumbran una cata
y de otro pensador francés de los 60 en
su libro seminal de society of
espectáculo decía que nuestra realidad
está mediada por imágenes y es así como
lo vivimos ahora 60 hace casi 70 años
después nos damos cuenta que en realidad
sin las redes sociales se han apoderado
de la manera en que nos conectamos
y hay otro pensador que también en los
60 un americano llamado rainer band am
escribe un libro que se llama theory and
design in the first marthineitz y él
presenta cuál es la historia de la
primera la segunda y la tercera era de
la máquina y vislumbra una cuarta era de
la máquina en donde dice ok ya nos
apropiamos de la tecnología pero ahora
la tecnología se está apropiando de
nosotros y está volviendo nos un
mecanismo de esta tecnología no es casi
un futuro fatalista pensar en esto hay
ejemplos de cómo interactuamos ya
virtualmente con las personas ya no
usamos el espacio público para vivir y
convivir hay hay datos que arrojan que
en nuestras vidas modernas vamos a pasar
5.5 años conectados a redes sociales
vamos esto significa por ejemplo salir a
pasear 93 mil veces a nuestro perro o ir
32 veces a la luna entonces hay una
desconexión total que está guiándonos
hacia lo virtual y desconectando nos de
los valores que físicamente podemos
compartir con la sociedad
otros ejemplos que no se vislumbran
en un futuro no deseable es la
proliferación de los boks los pods por
sus siglas en francés en inglés
significan the private
public spaces si pensábamos que el
espacio público es público porque es
para la sociedad hay empresas que
compran espacio público a los gobiernos
y estos espacios públicos están
restringidos a pesar de que como este en
londres que se el pop más grande de
europa parecen espacios en donde uno
puede convivir tranquilamente están
regulados si hay ciertas cosas que uno
no puede hacer afuera de estos pops por
ejemplo no sé si les ha tocado que de
repente están fotografiando un edificio
y el guardia les dice fuera de aquí no
puede usted fotografía como puede ser
posible estoy en la banqueta estoy en el
espacio público pues no es espacio
público fue comprado por esa ese
corporativo bueno
hay también ejemplos de cómo la sociedad
desde sus propios valores está cambiando
eso un ejemplo claro es el de hace unos
años vivimos en méxico esta
manifestación que dio pues que paro un
movimiento el movimiento de querer
construir un corredor cultural en
chapultepec cuáles son estas ideas
positivas esas ideas positivas vienen
normalmente desde lo desde la propia
disciplina creativa ha habido muchos
pensadores que desde desde su
perspectiva sobre todo en términos de
arquitectura y urbanismo han propuesto
ideas utópicas tal vez pero que hemos
apropiado y resignificado de manera no
utópica sino de un manera un poco más
tangible en nuestro día a día de cómo
resignificar el entorno que nos rodea
este primer ejemplo es el ejemplo de un
arquitecto inglés se llama se llamaba
cedric price un visionario del futuro y
este es uno de sus proyectos se llama
the phone palas y era una estructura
antes que albergar a alrededor de 50.000
y 55.000 visitantes y dotaba de
infraestructura cultural a una ciudad
entonces la gente podría llegar a
apropiarse de un teatro de un lugar para
dar talleres y esto se iba moviendo de
lugar en lugar otro ejemplo de otros
utópicos ingleses hay que ir a un
colectivo de arquitectos interesante
propuso en muchos proyectos entre ellos
dos que les presento de nombres muy
sugerentes este que se llama walking
city y living city que el mismo caso son
estas mega estructuras que llegan las
ciudades se re apropian del espacio y
permiten a la gente generar actividades
que le significan que les son
importantes para la propia sociedad y
este último ejemplo de las utopías es un
ejemplo de un arquitecto húngaro francés
llamado john afirman que proponen todos
sus proyectos utópicos estas mega
estructuras que llegaban y se
implantaban en la ciudad para del mismo
modo hacer que la gente se empoderar a
de sus posibilidades de apropiarse de la
ciudad
cuáles históricamente han sido las
soluciones que han propuesto las
disciplinas creativas o las
organizaciones creativas tenemos el
ejemplo en 1889 de una de las primeras
la primera ahorita les platico la
primera de una exposición universal todo
el mundo conocemos la torre eiffel
la torre eiffel estaba pensada para
hacer el hito el emblema de la de la
comunidad francesa dentro de esta gran
exposición universal ahí se ven
pabellones de algunos otros países y
estaba pensada como una estructura
efímera que iba a durar sólo 20 años
sin embargo esta estructura se quedó y
lo que ha significado desde el momento
que la construyó el ingeniero eiffel es
un espacio que permite más que un mito
arquitectónico un espacio en donde la
gente llega y se apropia de ese de esa
zona del río sena otros ejemplos en 1851
la primera exposición universal de great
the exhibition of all things en londres
en hyde park propuso el cristal para
hacer un espacio en donde se exhibía
diseño la primera vez que se exhibe
diseño de esta manera y lo que permite
es generar otros espacios que hoy en día
son los espacios más importantes del
corazón de la sociedad inglesa hi park y
todo su espacio alrededor y los museos
alrededor se generan a partir de esta
exposición 100 años después como
conmemoración de la exposición se genera
de festival o gritan es la primera vez
que se utiliza el río de una manera
cultural antes los ingleses no salían a
la calle inclusive morían por salir a la
calle en época de la reina victoria por
la contaminación y a partir de aquí los
ingleses caminan por él
y también si se generan cafés que dan a
la calle etc entonces esto es un cambio
de la sociedad inglesa pero que también
permea en toda la sociedad actualmente
qué soluciones encontramos que vemos que
hacen los pensadores y los críticos
tenemos el ejemplo de richard rogers un
arquitecto inglés también que muy
visionaria mente de definió que si no es
desde desde el propio gobierno que
genera políticas públicas es difícil que
como sociedad permanezcan estos momentos
que no se vuelve nada más momentos y que
no sino que se vuelvan realidad es
contundentes y que permanezcan en el
futuro
richard rogers con el medio de flow
donde ese entonces que en livingston
generó varias organizaciones dentro del
gobierno que permitieron crear proyectos
como android public spaces que permitían
que creadores se unieran con sociedad y
promovieran en la creación de nuevos
espacios públicos
en méxico cuáles cuáles son algunos de
los ejemplos en específico quiero
hablarles del festival que dirijo que es
el abierto mexicano de diseño que sucede
una vez al año en el centro histórico en
octubre y que su misión fundamental es
acercar el diseño a la sociedad la razón
por la que lo hacemos es en la medida
que conozcamos mejor nuestro entorno
físico nuestro nuestra cultura material
visual podemos responder mucho mejor a
ella el festival se apropia de recintos
culturales de gran riqueza para meter
las creaciones de diseñadores
contemporáneos mexicanos y extranjeros
pero también y sobre todo se apropia del
espacio público de la ciudad de mexico
que es el corazón de la ciudad del
centro histórico este es una instalación
del diseñador lumínico más importante a
nivel internacional morí total de media
esta es una instalación de un colectivo
arquitectura mexicano una instalación en
la plaza santo domingo de unos
diseñadores gráficos mexicanos una
instalación afuera
cerca del templo mayor de un colectivo
español e inglés una instalación en la
alameda central de una de un florista
que literalmente lanza flores al espacio
a su mamá coto japonés una instalación
de unos mexicanos héctor esrawe y nacho
cadena en la alameda central y una
instalación de dos ingleses diseñadores
gráficos morag majesco y look morgan en
el zócalo capitalino
con esta instalación doy fin a esta
plática para reforzar esta idea como
desde la sociedad creativa desde las
disciplinas creativas podemos proponer
en este caso
tal vez ejemplos un poco efímeros pero
que resignifican espacios específicos de
nuestra ciudad como de repente podemos
llegar al zócalo y colombianos en el
zócalo que de alguna u otra manera no lo
podríamos hacer si no es por la creación
de un festival o de pensadores creativos
que aportan que dotan de otros
significados al espacio público entonces
quiero que se vayan con esta idea de
cómo como sociedad podemos apropiarnos
acercarnos resignificar dar valor a este
espacio físico para generar conexiones y
para reforzar esas conexiones que son
necesarias en este mundo un poco más
análogo o digital eso es todo
buenas noches gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]